But that was wild out of context though. We're on the same page
there, right?
>> You're like a woman, Hitler. I mean, like Hitler. You're
kind of like a woman like Hitler. I don't know if he made his
response stream members only.
He's going to make that 10 grand back one way or another.
We're moving on to the next part of the stream, the Aba the Aba
part of the stream, okay?
Oh, dude. What?
Basically, what happened to catch you guys up, we're doing the
Abas the Aba baby mama stuff. Now, two new huge revelations with
the Aba content, okay?
One is that Aba was cheating on Libertine, she claims, with another
girl. He had a girlfriend in Montreal, all right? That girlfriend
in Montreal apparently got pregnant and got blocked in the same
All right? That's what she claimed within like I don't know,
10 minutes of the interview starting, okay? Big big big big But
it's going like if any of this is validated, it's going to be
nuts. >> Did you hear about Aba's
because there's one thing he said that and it kind of turned
me sour on him a while back. He was doing an interview, a public
interview, and he had said that he likes to be milked
and
I don't know if you know what this means. Maybe you do, maybe
you guys have some experience with this, but
Bro. Yeah, Aba likes getting his prostate played with and he
talked about this openly on a stream for some reason.
I don't know why. He talked about it openly on a stream.
How he likes to be milked. It's it's
>> Oh, I'm sorry. What was your question? Oh, you were
talking about Filipinos being very conservative and that some
are very liberal.
>> Yes, and in the case of Aba, he did a public interview
and he said that he likes to be milked and my understanding and
I'm a very vanilla simple person, so I don't >> Bro, did
you see Did you see she evil? She's actually evil.
Hold on. Am I the only one who got that? Am I the only one who
got that? Am I the only one No, everybody got that. Everybody
got that. >> milked and
I under her ass.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, I see you. I see you. I see you. >> And
I'm >> tried. You can just tell she's like biting down
on her lips to like try to not seem like she's laughing.
Oh, boy. Oh, boy. >> vanilla simple person, so I don't
know entirely what all these
uh terms mean, but it sounded like if I understand correctly,
he had wanted the woman to go up his backside or something like
that.
>> I don't know. >> Were you aware of that?
>> I did not hear about that before I dated >> Oh,
no.
Oh, no. Oh, no. Hold on. Hold on. >> Oh, no.
>> Mhm. And I just heard it as being milked and I didn't
know about it I until like afterwards. Until after the >> breakup,
you heard that he >> Uh until like after after like the
relationship started and everything like that. And I'm going
to be honest, I just tried not to judge
and that that was it.
>> I looked too >> He's asking you if you shoved
anything up that guy's ass. That's what he That's what he's asking
you, lady.
He debased himself enough to ask the question. Please have the
balls to answer back. Listen, he he debased himself by asking
the question, okay?
And she's like, I heard about it when we started the relationship.
But she didn't say
that they did that, right? It's a little different. into >> and
then I just hear people like fun of it and then I'm just trying
to not to
>> Okay. So so does that mean that you
be with a guy who does that or you could not? Cuz I I presume
that you didn't say that was a relationship ender. >> I
don't think
>> Dude, yeah. I'm telling you this guy wants to kill Abba
like he wants to nuke Abba as much as possible. That's why he's
willing to ask these questions,
So are you saying that's like not a deal breaker for you then?
Trying to gross her into being like
into making a declaration?
>> Uh so I don't really know what milking is. I think it's
talking about like being From what I understand when I saw >> Yes,
I want your definition of milking. Thank you. >> people
when they're milked they're like
right? That's what That's how you are milked. >> That's
what I I'm not going to lie to you. I don't even know cuz I'm
from LA and we don't really do all that stuff. >> Okay.
Okay, I'm dying. Yeah, there aren't any gay people in LA. Nobody's
shoving stuff up each other's in LA, buddy. Yeah. Yeah, totally
no. No, no,
People in LA, oh they would never. They would never. In the butt?
No. No.
Bro,
what the are you talking about, man? I don't even know what that
[__] is, man. I DON'T EVEN KNOW YEAH, I DID DESCRIBE
THINGS GOING UP HIS BACKSIDE. YEAH, I did say it precisely just
2 seconds ago. Bro, I'm from LA. Could you imagine if there were
gay people in LA? Could you Could you imagine that? >> I
don't know if Canada's hitting different, but if somebody in
the chat can send me a link and a timestamp send me a link and
a timestamp cuz I I'm curious. Um but we can carry on with that,
but based on your understanding that you currently have of it,
that's not a relationship ender.
>> I didn't think it was that cuz the way he described
it in like one of his interviews when I saw it was like which
is more forgiving than being dead. I don't think I can be with
someone who's like being but it was just like uh more like how
do I can I say this like
a girl like more like just like playing with that area but not
like actually
that it can still
but not not any not any like pe- in that area or anything like
that. My understanding is just like stimulating that that area
but like anything in there I don't I think that's what the way
he described it in the interview I was like that was uh it didn't
seem I don't know.
>> Okay. Okay. It wasn't too much of a violation for you.
>> Yeah I think like being
like any in there would have probably definitely bothered me.
Or definitely been a deal breaker.
I just want to remind you okay because you might feel like this
is really [__] up. What I would say is I just want
to remind you it is [__] up okay. We'll say it's
[__] up. She shouldn't be doing this. It shouldn't
be public. But
Abel is out. He was out. He had a clean
And he burned the [__] out because of that Instagram
and he set himself on fire. I have no idea man. >> I was
wondering cuz I was like you know people aren't going to say
everything on camera. I was like maybe bro was like I'm going
to just let this out on camera and I'm going to hold in the rest
and just see how people react to that. But yeah that was crazy
like I'm not going to lie to you in the end.
>> Yeah and he's very liberal like that. He's I've never
done anything like that with him. Um so and I don't know if I'd
feel comfortable doing that particularly but like yeah he's never
asked me to do anything like that.
>> Okay that's a blessing. That that's really good. I mean
unfortunately it's one of those things that I think they they
hold off on that and then hit you with that when you're locked
in but you know that's a blessing. Okay very good. Um and what
else we got? So it says oh yeah preach. Um one of the things
that I think was highlighted in his video and in full uh honesty
I've not seen his whole video.
Maybe I saw 15 minutes of it, but I understand that in his video
he said that she had reached out to Preach, his
Had you had any interaction with Preach before that? Like met
him in person or talked with him or anything like that? >> If
the worst example of like stalking or going crazy to get around
a block
is like four circumventions
one time. I don't know, man. I I don't know.
I kind of
Yeah, I don't know. I don't know if I feel like that's That's
not enough to explain like a lot of the other stuff going on
here.
I understand that everybody's like, "Oh, no, you can never You
can never circumvent a block." No, I mean people do all the time.
Romantic relationships, obviously this happens all the time.
I don't know. I'm sorry. I just don't think it's like the most
crazy insane thing in the world.
>> I promise that I have never ever tried to reach out
to anybody other than Preach, the I'm in Preach page, and of
course Abba. But he's like he's constantly painting this narrative
that stop contacting my family, stop contacting my friends. And
he does that because that's just how he talks and that's how
he fights. When he wants to insult or provoke you, he does exaggerate,
and he didn't want to paint me in that light. But >> Very
very feminine behavior again. >> I would even ask Abba
like please provide the proof for that if you do have it. And
I'm I'm telling him to do that right now if he you know if he
ever if he ever sees
>> That's a very valid point, and we do invite Abba to
provide the evidence of that just in as much as it's only fair,
and I encourage the fans >> Boundaries don't mean the people
without them. Shut up.
Uh Abba is the person who also doesn't have any boundaries. I'm
saying within the context of that toxic relationship, I don't
think she's like going out of this out of this world. Like
you don't get to just like block somebody who's pregnant with
your kid and then not expect a circumvention of a >> on
reaching out to Abba after being blocked multiple times.
One Filipino to another Filipino. >> Yeah, hi there. It
was just because I was I thought I thought I was talking to the
Abba that I was I perceived from Abban Preach. And so I would
give it every time something happened, I would just give it the
benefit of the doubt. And I'm like, you know, it's a few months
in. >> That's a stupid excuse. Oh, I thought even though
I'd been dating him for a while and he showed himself to be really
emotional, like kind of a [__] I thought I was dating
I was I thought I was dealing with like the caricature from his
show, from his YouTube channel where he plays a character. I
thought that's who I was No, you didn't. >> Maybe I'm just
going to give it the benefit of the doubt and that's my honest
answer, like And also it's like, am I causing this? Um but over
time I'm like, I don't think this is okay to be blocking after
every conflict.
>> Listen, I'm not uh I'm not starting on this lady, but
if you had a mind to, if you had a mind to like really start
looking into it's weird that she's
she's this calm while being like
fundamentally dishonest on some stuff, I feel like, right? Like
I feel like there's a lot of just foundational dishonesty she
employs
where I know she's not as dumb as she's pretending to be and
she does it so
and then she sometimes she'll just say something that she trips
up a little bit, but uh there's like some fundamental dishonesty
going on here, man. >> Yeah, and you know, it's weird cuz
I I definitely observed that you were being a woman in the worst
ways, but it seems like he was participating in it with you,
which is why I stayed alive. >> When you say I was being
a woman in the worst ways during the blocking?
Or after >> just in general, changing your mind, going
back and forth on things, being
>> You're like a woman
Hitler. I mean like Hitler. You're kind of like a woman like
Hitler. >> During the pregnancy, I would say my
was crazy. Yes. Before that
um I would say
I I would say it wasn't bad. I'm I if I if I I'm going to defend
myself everything with the indecisiveness regarding the pregnancy
and him blocking me after that.
Yes, but before that I think the blocking was kind of like unwarranted
to be honest. The amount of times I was blocked by Abba. >> Oh,
you're saying so you think that he really defaulted to that in
terms of using instead of using conflict
>> Yeah, if you I don't know if you saw I'm pretty sure
you saw the
the videos
and the screen recordings. The screen recordings were always
just like him blocking me after each conflict and
and then he would unblock me and that's just his his go-to and
I would always tell him like hey can you unblock me and I'm able
to do that after yeah, he just resorts to blocking and that's
his thing. I don't know what else to say about that then other
than like that's what he resorts to is the blocking. >> Um
generalization rights did he tell you that he was unable to have
kids?
>> He told me that he had a low sperm
>> I'm not going to lie when I heard that I was LIKE I
KNEW IT. I KNEW IT. I knew >> But he but I'm only saying
that now because he had also said it on the and he also told
the other girl that he got pregnant that he had a low sperm count.
So I don't know if it's to just >> Now I'm wondering if
he was finessing just to hit raw.
>> That's what her and I were talking about. I have her
video up here of like we were talking and
she saw the video and she was like she got to reach out to me
and she felt bad because she said that she experienced the same
things and she emailed Abba. She had to email him because Abba
blocked her and >> Oh wow. This man has a pattern. He has
a system he's running you through.
Like it's a little crazy, no? >> Yeah, um and she was like
I can't believe like you're saying these things about her. You
know, some things are true. I definitely am not innocent here
and I'm not trying to I know I'm not innocent here. Um but she
was like she saw a lot of the same things that I was seeing and
and then he reached out to her while we were talking and she
ended up having a phone call with him and she's like, "What the
heck? Like, you were talking to her while you were talking to
me. You said that she was this big cheater for making this Instagram,
which we
>> Nick apologize.
Nick Scalo in the chat, apologize to me now. Apologize to me
now. Um, Abba Abba totally had a reason to be like a total Abba
total crash out about this. No, he's projecting and emotional
because he's a feminine performative man.
That's what was happening there. >> probably would talk
about. But Abba really was like, "You're such a
um, you're a Jezebel. You're so pathetic. Grow the >> Turns
out he was telling that to you. >> Yeah, that was the catalyst
of why I decided to come out with anything in the first place.
Um, was my last interaction with him. And um, I was never going
to say anything, but after like, I tried so hard to end things
right and peacefully despite all the the >> Also, I will
say, I would need some evidence to this. She has She has like
lied about some stuff before.
I would need some evidence to this before I just hop on the on
the boat of like, "Oh, this is totally true." We need some evidence.
>> the problems that we had. And it did take a lot emotionally
because I just truly wanted him to be good. And I know that he
wanted me to be good, too. But because of his personality, he
he is the kind of person that needs to leave things on bad terms
cuz I think it's easier that way for some people to like hate
the person. And um, that's not the case with him. So, I just
wanted to end things right despite how, you know, on my end this
is my what I experienced is that I did feel like I endured a
lot with him. And I don't know if you saw the leaked phone call.
Did
>> I I don't think so.
there's a leaked phone call. I think you might be interested
to watch that. He's yelling at me. Um, the rage he has in that
>> Oh, we might have to We might have to be We might have
to be watch that phone call, okay? We may have to give it a look
cuz I do believe
we get more crashing out of that. >> Just try to understand
that this was the reaction I would get from him all the time.
So, this isn't this isn't just like a one-off for him. This is
the >> who hang over that door over my head, I want you
gone. Even if you don't agree with my top five list of the greatest
movies of all time, you're horrible. So, I don't want you >> Why
am I horrible?
I need to
>> Uh come on. I go into it right away.
I The second you hear something like
oh yeah?
Why do you hate me? It's like, uh-huh. Yeah, okay. Whatever you
say. Yeah, I'm done talking.
I know I'm get I know what I'm getting
I know.
Why don't you go into a detail about how much I suck?
>> I need to know what How have I been so horrible TO YOU?
>> ABA, NO! ABA, DON'T FALL FOR IT. ABA! ABA, YOU GOT TO
RUN. >> OVER TIME, I see the bigger things happen and I'm
like still conflicted. I'm I'm still wanting to kind of >> Okay.
We know a lot of this. I'm going to the next like the next question.
>> wristwear and
This is one of the least masculine
black males you're going to observe anywhere. He has not a muscle
in sight.
>> He wears the most I hate the has a a chain with a a
a a a a a ring on it wears strange wristwear and He has like
hippy black guy vibes and and I love it and I love that for him.
But, there's nothing even minimally masculine about >> Uh
it just feels like
I legitimately feel little a little bad for Aba just in that
he was like into this person and she's like
Like basically she's going on shows where all they want to do
is denigrate Aba like maximally, right? Like that's all they
want to do. It feels like, okay, you want to post your stuff
and get your word out there. That's fine. But, then to me,
when you go on something like this, the goal is to like destroy
him. The goal is to like hurt him maximally.
Like she feels bad as it happens? Yeah, I don't know about that.
>> about the way he comes off. And you said you watched
him on Aba and Preach. Like if you watch the show, like he doesn't
come off that way. And he also doesn't come off like he's trying
to be anything. He comes off effortless. He's in a state of relaxation.
He is what he is. But
I just find it to be really bizarre, especially if you grew up
in uh not Los uh Orange County. You grew up in killer Cali. You
you've seen some real men before. You've seen the masculinity
that is typical of the black
Bro is devoid of all masculinity. Like even in the comments,
as you were saying that, people were like, "He's feminine as
hell." It's like You're a tweaker, >> That's funny.
I was attracted to Aba. I I Okay. My taste normally very masculine
men. Maybe even like hyper-masculine a little bit.
>> Aw, come on.
>> Come on.
But they're talking about how this guy this guy was not
not really a man. >> I'M WHAT ARE YOU TALKING SO FAR OFF?
What are you talking about? >> What I What attracted me
to Aba was
his virtues and the morals that he he
always talked about on stream.
And how he seemed like he was Honestly, he would say a lot of
things that were great. And I was like, "Oh, there's something
very interesting about this guy. I like the things he said."
>> Uh is that No. No. Aba! Aba!
Aba Aba, was she a fan before you guys got together?
Was she a fan?
>> When you say salsa dancing is the workout, I'm like,
"Oh, hell no. Hell no." If this boy ain't Puerto Rican and salsa
dancing is his form of workout, like come on.
I depends what's the point of being masculine. What What is the
point of If you're being masculine for other guys,
then that's totally fine.
But like straight up, if you're if you're being masculine cuz
you want to get women, then I'm sorry. I'm sorry, bro.
Have a good clean up at the salsa club. That's all I'm saying.
>> All sis. >> Like we're we're tripping right now.
>> Like I I'm sorry. If you if you are getting masculine
for other men, if you're you're lifting weights or you're like
boxing so you could show off to other guys, that's an insecurity
issue. Beyond like yeah, it's an insecurity issue and also possibly
a gay issue. So,
I just feel like most guys want to get masculine cuz they're
thinking about women and women don't really care. Like some level
of masculinity is good, but I'm saying that like it's more in
the attitude than it is in the And I think Abba did a good job
of projecting like a masculine
a masculine persona.
If not like his his body is like physique and stuff wasn't masculine,
but like the persona was like calm and
centered and in control, right? That was the persona he gave
off. >> Sometimes a woman's not there as a gold digger.
She's not there for the money.
You know, but if I'm just assuming and I don't know, but he strikes
me as a he wasn't like the cool kid in high school or college
or elementary school, middle And so it's like if he wasn't a
a lame with money
or a lame with fame, would you have messed with him? Like try
to think through it though.
Like nobody knows who he is. You You didn't find him on YouTube.
>> Again, just uh just basically saying Abba's kind of
a bum, right? Abba's kind of a bum, right? Is he like a total
bum? >> You saw him on Instagram, but as he actually is
without all the following and comments.
>> It's like a total bomb. >> Yeah, I'm going to
be honest with with them. I think it's clear
the whole status thing is a thing. Okay.
I watched his channel maybe 6 years like since the pandemic.
I saw him and and like I was like, "Okay, not I'm not even thinking
about attraction. It took me the sixth year to be like, "Oh,
like I like what this guy's talking about." So,
I like if I was to meet this guy in person, probably not because
it would take me a really long time to find that stuff out about
him. And then find out like, "Okay, like I
you know, he has a good heart and everything like that." But
I was able to find Aba because of his platform. >> And
she's about to cope over these messages where she's like offering
this. I he's got a he's got a nuker over these messages, right?
These are the messages she sent this Watts TV guy who's a creator
who knows Aba. And she goes, "I'll give you money to just review
like my videos and see if it makes sense." And then she's like,
"I wasn't trying to leak this stuff. I just wanted someone's
I just wanted someone's opinion, man. Come on. >> a question
for a lot of people and
before getting into this,
didn't know what what I was doing. And people in my circle knew
knew my treatment how my treatment was from Aba and they were
like, "Expose the guy, right?" So, I'm like, "I'm not going to
totally listen to them. I'm going to reach out to just a few
content creators and ask what their opinion is."
Everyone in the comments are saying that I was paying off other
content creators to spread this narrative.
This is the exact same message I sent to all of the content creators,
which were only like three.
I would like to share this because everyone's saying, I don't
know, tell me what you think. And it was genuinely to just get
a um an opinion. So, it said, not sure what happened, but you
didn't see what you said. Oh, cuz I had deleted it because honestly
I was going back and forth on whether or not Abby wanted to talk
about this. Hey, sorry. I deleted cuz I keep going back and forth
on how much I wanted to share. I did not I did want to comp I
did want to compensate you for your time if you helped me. I
probably need like 1 and 1/2 hours of your time. I said something
lower earlier, but I really need a thoughtful response and I
feel that's worth more. Would 300 be good for uh 2 hours of your
time um just to review some things. I'm I'm sure if I want to
go out with this publicly and uh with what the experience I had
with Aba. Um I was Aba's ex-girlfriend from Aba and Preach question,
uh why come to me? >> It's like totally fine, right? >> to
your channel and you I've seen you cover their stuff. I need
someone who knows Aba's personality.
>> Oh, no, no, Nick's, come on. She's not even really checking
anything. She's basically just going, hey, I'm going to show
you this. You're like a drama guy, right? What's going to happen?
You're going to leak this? Or maybe you'll leak this. Maybe you'll
just leak it out of nowhere. I don't know. I don't know what's
happening. >> Oh, and I'm not asking you to post this or
advocate
>> came to you with all of this, would you gas it up or
tell her what she needs to hear? Um I would say you can post
this publicly. I don't I'm not evaluating it or giving you notes.
That's it. That's all you can ever say.
I Sometimes
this guy did a little bit
I would say also if somebody's bringing me something in private,
usually the the if it's someone who's like, hey, this person
wronged me
and they're not an internet person I'm like, you have no idea
what this is going to do if you do this. It's not going to make
your life better. You really don't know, so you you can figure
it out on your own, whatever you want to do, but just think about
it.
I You don't want to put your private life on the internet. You
they still want to do that, okay? Usually give that advice. Don't
want to put your private life on the internet. You need to You
need to chill.
And it won't make you happy. It's always like rumination, too.
Like people kind of spiraling on something, and they put it out
on the internet. It's like, no. No, don't do that. Don't do that
to
Trust me. Unless you were really wrong, do you feel like you
have to protect other people? In which case, put together like
a a document or something yourself, and then I'll cover it if
you post it >> I just need an opinion. There it is. He
says, "Send what you have." I sent him. Um and then he basically
tells me no.
And I talked to other people, and this is just him saying no,
I don't think you should do it. I said, "Hey, thanks for watching.
I didn't expect you to talk about this for content." Cuz he's
saying like, "I don't feel comfortable doing it." And I said,
"I wouldn't ask that. I reached out to you initially for an opinion,
which gave you uh which you gave me, so thanks. I came in knowing
people are going to wonder who I am and what Abba site is. I
thought about everything you mentioned before, even thinking
about sharing all this. And I wouldn't go out with these if I
knew Abba wouldn't have would have
Okay. I'm going to skip to the next one. She's got another one
she's going to explain. Different set of rules. >> I just
said this out of nowhere. Um I'm going to show you where that
>> to the top real quick? >> Oh, I'll get back >> Do
you want to start from the beginning or can I get to this part
first and then go back? >> Yeah, yeah. Okay, sure. Do what
you want to do. You're the blue.
>> I'm the blue. Yeah. So, Abba pointed out this to everybody.
I'm going to kill the baby, lol. Okay. He just made it sound
like >> Oh, this is like scummy from Abba, as well. Abba
does this a lot. And I don't think anyone's really going to call
him on it. >> That was wild. >> This is not cool.
>> That was wild. Am I Am I tripping or was that wild?
>> There needs to be context. So. >> But that was
wild out of context, though. We're on the same page there, >> A
thousand percent. All right. But that's what he wanted to That's
what he wanted to do. So, I'm going back up to the chat. We get
into one of our normal fights.
He blocks me again.
And I'm like, "Okay, sorry. I'll >> Right. Good. Do what
you got to do and kill the child. Is
what he says first in this argument. And then eventually, after
a little while of arguing, she goes, "Okay, I'm just going to
kill the kid then." Right? And then he presented that in a vacuum
to make it look like she wasn't just sort of throwing that back
at him. Right? Like it's one thing if she was just saying that
in a vacuum, that's crazy. It is way, way, way less crazy when
he's the one who said it first.
Right? Now, let's assume you can't go up in this and find a place
where she actually said it before that as well. I'm not totally
sure, but like as that
that's crazy. >> I'll start with you. >> Thanks for
everything. Good. Do what you got to do and kill the child. And
then that's when you see me like, I understand, and he's like,
"No wonder you're Oh. So, I spiral and it kind of gets too deep
now and dramatic and he says, uh "Yeah, so it all starts from
what he says here." And then I'm going in and then he shows like
the sleeping pill stuff, which I don't actually take. I just
end up falling asleep in the car.
and so, I
end up just
>> That was kind of strike me as low IQ for going that
far with it and not expecting it to blow up in his face.
Oh, it doesn't have anything to do with IQ. He's just in his
emotions right here, right?
He could be the smartest He could be a genius. He could be Albert
Einstein and still do this. This has nothing to do with your
IQ. He is not engaging his like long-term me medium-term
like processing. He's not thinking of anything except he's like
extremely emotionally dysregulated and he's going to make this
person hurt the way he hurts. That's like the only thing he could
think of right now. >> Mocking what he's saying. So, >> Oh,
presenting it like that after the fact. Yeah. Yeah, that's to
me yeah, that was stupid. That was quite dumb. >> to I'm
going to do what I have to do and kill the baby, right? Like
um and saying what he's saying. So, I'm just mocking what he's
saying over and over again.
but not because I'm saying it out of nowhere. It's more like
>> Did she actually say
Wait, hold on. Are these the same ones?
Wait, let me get this and go back to
Hold on. Hold on.
>> So, I would >> Okay. Okay. >> out this text.
>> Okay. Wait, where is this now?
Cuz this is a different one. This is I'm going to kill the baby
LOL.
Right? Then we go to here. Now, what what's the name of the machine
here? >> Oh, I'm going to kill the baby, right? >> Now,
she says that with the quotes like afterwards, but I don't know
Oh, that's earlier on.
Okay. Okay. Okay. So, she He says kill the baby. She says she
does the quote thing and then she says it without the quotes
later on the call. I got it. Or later on the text stream. >> just
mocking what he's saying over and over again. Um but not because
I'm saying it out of nowhere. It's more like, "Oh, I'm going
to kill the baby, right?" Like cuz that's what she said. Like
you know what I'm saying? Do you understand what I'm
>> Nick, are you really on this level of sweeping right
now?
It's a bit much, isn't it? That broom seems mighty happy. That
seems like an insanely happy broom. I don't know if I don't know
if that's possible. I don't know if these comments could be swept
in this way. >> I do comprehend your English, yes.
>> Sorry, do you understand what I'm >> crazy sweeping
right there.
so when I say this, it's um I'm saying I'm going to kill the
baby. You're right, that's what >> I don't know if she's
canceled multiple abortions at this point. Probably at least
one, but I don't know. >> I'm doing. It's because he's
saying like go ahead, kill the baby. So to me that was my reaction.
I'm just like mocking him and saying like oh you're going to
say I'm going to kill the baby. Okay, like that. But he when
he pointed it out he he pointed this out specifically
out of context. It wasn't me like being like hahaha yeah I'm
going to kill the baby. It was like me mocking him saying like
you keep saying I'm going to kill the baby. Okay, like you're
like >> They're using his language.
>> Yeah, so that's what um is happening
>> Why do you think he was saying FU you killed our kid?
Like did he want to have the kid and raise it with you? Like
>> The pattern I'm trying to show is that when Abba gets
upset he will say anything to provoke you. He will he will dig
at your >> I think I think she's like totally correct in
just showing this pattern.
Like she is totally correct. He's like crashing out. He's overstating
things. He's like He's being very hyperbolic.
He's doing it intentionally just to try to hurt the other person.
Right? He's like using the things that he can. I think she was
doing the same thing back to him.
But I I it seems like he is
He's just like totally emotionally dysregulated. I don't know
what's going on with him, man. >> your vulnerabilities
and so this is one of them um one of the other times where he's
talking about like he was like this is this hasn't been her first
time.
This stuff is on a different level I think. Like people don't
say stuff that he does. Um >> Where did Big Bird? >> Um
okay, so this is the day
>> Where did Big Bird? Where did Big Bird? Where did Big
Bird?
>> He's like your new idea ended up on my for you page.
To be honest with you it was pretty crazy. I understand why you
hid it from me. I didn't hide it from him. You weren't honest
about what it was considering the comments you made about what
I thought. I can't help but feel I was so stupid and played for
a fool. Um I didn't lie about any of it. Again, when I tell you
he exaggerates >> This guy is just like a pure
Is grifter the right word even? Like scam artist?
Like grifter is probably the right word. Scam artist, like
I just there's not much going on here. Maybe he at least maybe
he box or he
There's maybe that.
It's um it's one of those people who has
like this weird like confidence is knowing what you could do,
what you can't do. Bravado is just having no idea what you can't
do and just basically you've disconnected the brakes of the car
that is confidence, right? And it's just going to like fly down
the the road and crash into whatever. Like that's what he is.
He has no real understanding of his limitations or he totally
ignores it intentionally cuz he knows that as long as he puts
on a bravado, he will convince everybody that he knows what he's
doing, that he's like
It's just weird. It's it's just weird watching somebody do it
and then I've watched him like embarrass himself talking about
multiple different topics and he's just clearly a a grifter or
scam artist in so many
It's just it's weird to now watch him try to do the red pill
thing and be like this is the way this is. I was like, uh-huh.
You don't know anything, dog.
The Marquet guy uh I just agrees to everything I was saying right
now. He's kind of funny.
I was sounds like a red pill or yeah.
We're sorry to and then
I guess I can show you some more. So this is the treatment that
I'm getting all the time. >> I feel my real quick though.
In these in these messages, I'm seeing a lot of black with no
blue. Is this man just typing out these whole damn paragraphs
with like no responses?
>> I'm just like what the heck is your problem? Again,
why are you doing this?
Give me all my money back, you stupid
lying lying cheating [__]
She's like what the
what the >> You see what I'm talking about? I finally respond
to
And he's like he's like I feel bad. Feel free to just refund
me every penny I spent on your boarding self.
Cool. Cool. Cool.
>> Which is funny cuz I used to say thank you. You won't
but I feel less stupid if I had to send money to a scammer or
a girl. You know what? I won't do this. Sorry, I have to do this
for you I >> Uh Ava's not going to react to any of this
stuff, I don't think. I Although at this point I feel like this
is the problem, right? Cuz he already said he was out.
I don't think this is why you just don't respond. If you don't
respond, you don't
But he already went to her video and he comments under the video,
I'm out. I'm
Now if she's lied outright, which she has at least once or twice
that I've seen that I've caught, I'm sure Ava if she's lied other
times, he can catch
But he's already said, what are you going to do now? You already
said you were out. You already said you weren't going to respond
anymore. What are you going to do?
>> Instead of throwing this thing, um I think I'll send
it back to you. Then you can get your call. I don't care. If
you work for it or if you have your new shoe ready to wear and
send it and send it. Just give me a call when I said Ava, when
I made the page, I was please check the dates on her first post.
You you had me blocked and I was alone responding to the comments.
Chat GPT told me for the algorithm and I'm just like no. >> You
let Chat GPT ruin your relationship? You better go play it out
here. >> Yeah, I was just trying to say that was the only
reason why I'm commenting on all the comments. Um he's like still
lying. Just send the money. You'll always have anxiety and panic
attacks because you're lying to yourself at this point. But deep
down >> What do you mean about money? He wanted his money
back? He wanted a refund? >> This is all he can say about
how Ava responds. Yeah, I guess he wanted a refund. He's like
um I don't like reading a million more lies from a cheating cheating
attention >> If Ava were to respond because of misinfo,
yeah, that's probably what he'll do. Like yeah, I Look guys,
I was going to let it go. I was done commenting, but she she
lied multiple times. Alba made his response stream members only.
He's going to make that 10 grand back one way or another.
There's something about this that I
Oh, man.
Yeah, shit's tough. Shit's
I feel like
you would be shocked how many people, if you're just willing
to be offended and angry, will just assume a position of like,
"I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I'm sorry." I Anybody who like
figures that out it's it's probably tough for them not to abuse
that sometimes. Do you know what I mean? That like if you're
sufficiently upset with someone, they will the other person will
start apologizing to you. And then that could become a dynamic.
Although, I don't know I don't know if that's like Alba, maybe
he's just like this a lot, or cuz she she has no reason to be
apologizing here to feel sorry at all. It's actually crazy how
like not in the wrong she is in this one specific instance. >> Did
you cheat on him?
>> I have never cheated on him. The only If you If you
see this here, the only way The only reason why he's talking
to me like this is because he found the Instagram. And I can
show you why. I can prove that because >> So, I just want
to make sure you're stating that he is claiming you having an
Instagram account is cheating. >> Me having an Instagram
account and responding to all of the comments is cheating on
him.
>> Do you think that's >> That's not what I think.
I mean, it doesn't matter what we think. It just matters what
the facts are. The facts are that no, that's not cheating, especially
for a guy who claims to be liberal, and also who's in the social
media business. If you're engaging it as a business, yes, engaging
your consumer or your fan is going to drive more, you know, of
the content being propagated. Now, would I date a woman who wants
to be an influencer? Hell no, I wouldn't do that. But if I do
encounter a woman, I respect her based on how I found her. I'm
not trying to change her into something she is not. If I found
her and she wants to be an influencer or she's a gym girl and
has gym content, I'm going to respect what it is. I'm not going
to try to change you into Abba, preach, and
Hold on. Didn't she give him rules that not to be allowed to
speak? No, that's another thing. Like Abba tried to paint me
the Everything Abba said in that stream, he had no proof of.
He's just good with his words. And so it made me it made me look
like I'm this crazy psycho girlfriend stalker who wanted to kill
herself because I like he would break up with me. Um Everything
he said in there, he's not He only provided the small pieces
of proof because that's all he had. I'm providing like all of
this stuff because he actually did this stuff. Um I know there's
things that you can't prove uh like through screenshots and stuff
like that, but he um No, I I was never a jealous girl girlfriend
like that. That one girl I asked him to stop holding me is because
like it was like twerking like and it didn't make me feel like
I >> crazy. So So yeah, and that's why you need a simp
because you're trying to run a man's program. Like that was madness.
But I think that you guys are both kooky. You're kooky and Abba
are kooky. So low-key you guys are kind of a good match. Y'all
are It's an explosive match. You're a good little toxic match,
you two. >> Okay. Um I was thinking I I I get ahead of
>> You just got to let it go sometimes. >> Yeah.
Um when I saw the dates and what you were doing weren't good,
I was like you can block me. So I have anxiety and panic attacks,
which is not That's not something This is something he pulled
out of his ass. Um I'm bringing myself from how kooky you were
to me that your soul is happy either you or your behavior. Um
I'm excited to come because I didn't want to leave you. So when
I was feeling like that, um it was like I didn't want to leave
you. This is What he's talking about here was what happened months
before. Um and you will continue to suffer as long as you would
be his wife. >> Does she show proof of Abba cheating? No.
No, I've not seen any of that proof yet. We should maybe scan
for it. I'm just looking I've got one last timestamp and then
I think we could just free scan through to the end. Do you think
she shows any of the stuff that she said
but we've not seen evidence of yet?
Let me see here. 3:58. Never mind, we've gone past all my timestamps,
so >> I think he's making this up. He had a full-on girl
he was sleeping with while he was getting mad at me for his >> Okay,
let me announce to the folks in what they're saying real quick
as you >> So the reason the reason he's calling you cheating
because she had an
I do believe they were fully broke Oh.
Oh, hold on. They're fully broken up. If if she's saying oh if
she's saying while he was getting mad over the Instagram
at that point in April they were fully broken up.
So that's not fair. If he had a girl back in February and he's
when he was getting like basically she was posting the Instagrams
the Insta post in February. If he had a girl then then he's a
total [__] If he had a girl in April and was still
crashing out that's really embarrassing.
That's like probably even more embarrassing. Um probably if I
saw that if I was that person's partner like the crash out that's
just be crazy right?
Like if if I had a partner crash out on an ex that hard while
I'm dating them I feel like that'd be rough man.
You know what I mean?
Like I feel like you've just shown me that you're definitely
not over that. You are not over that even remotely.
You're like crazy crazy
crazy obsessed with whoever that was that you just had this insane
crash out >> after it. Uh first person writes um question
how many times have you used the strap on him? >> Okay.
Never.
>> Okay. Uh resident cat writes girl wtf this is a person
with no name no photo we can almost never trust these folks.
Uh you're exposing yourself to these red pill grifters. I personally
always spoken against red pill I think it's rubbish. Aba doesn't
sell courses to hurt men right he just makes fun of people and
gets paid to criticize all day. Uh sorry that you feel hurt by
your breakup drama. I don't think this person feels sorry at
all this is one of those effeminate males who speaking passive
aggressive language. You did this to yourself they don't uh they
don't believe you stop. Oh I think there's plenty of people who
believe you. In fact I've seen a higher number of women on the
stream than average. I think there's a good number of people
who believe you but half the time you don't need people to believe
you right you're showing the documentation. So what is there
to doubt? Jump to Marcus he writes she had a hinge account it
was verified on
>> Um I probably did have a hinge account at some point.
Yeah.
>> Was it at any point during the time of you the first
time you officially were in a relationship with Aba to the time
you broke up?
>> No but I did have a >> at some point you had one.
I can't speak up on too many of the Asians. Um very good. Carrying
on, someone sent me a uh a uh
Said you got blocked in the YouTube chat. Okay, let me take a
look at that. >> Cool. I got What was the question? >> Uh,
is is Abba a beta male? >> It's already in the comments.
Fourth What's the last thing he says?
Yeah, so it's just him saying like >> I don't really think
there's a whole lot else here. I don't know, we can watch for
a little
Go on. >> Uh, I think that's it.
Yeah, the rest is just him.
Yeah, I don't >> How do you be over that after the breakup
and pregnancy drama?
Because he they had like their like parting of ways.
Like he might not be over it. I'm just saying if I was like dating
somebody they crashed it over their ex that hard, I would be
like, yeah, bye. I'm not I'm not doing this.
Like you need to sort your [__] out. Why It's not
even objectionable what I'm >> It's a long It's a long
thread and then I uh
I think that's it. Yeah, and he's just sending me I think these
are the shots were pathetic.
I'll always remember the cheater and the fraud and every value
you've claimed. >> That's like not even remotely objectionable.
Like obviously you are crashing out. You have
you you you're like not over it. You're not emotionally available.
You're not ready to have a relationship. Don't even pretend,
okay? It's over. >> What are we talking about? We're talking
about how he reacted to your Instagram,
>> I didn't expect the Instagram to I was like building
a following. I was trying to >> What? Why were you trying
to build a >> Um, it was not to but hold on. Let me be
honest with myself here for a minute. I >> I appreciate
that. >> Cuz he He was about to call her a liar. So she's
like, wait, let me be Hold on. Let me be Wait, I was about to
lie. Let me be like honest with myself.